so joe biden today invited police
officials from across the country to the
white house to discuss
surging crime in city after city most of
them
cities that are run by democrats for
decades states run by democrats for
decades but unfortunately
the biden white house refuses to take
any responsibility
for their role in spewing the defund
police agenda
and their role in making communities
less safe less secure
more violent for example washington d.c
marked a grim milestone over this past
weekend
after it hit 100 homicides by july the
10th
that's the earliest the city has hit
that number since get this
2003. chicago 11
killed 35 wounded violence over the
weekend
in other words a typical weekend in the
windy city
do you know any of the names of any of
the people that were shot and shot and
killed this weekend in chicago i doubt
it
why because the left in this country as
we have pointed out for
years on this show only seems to care
about the lives of people
killed when they can then use their
death to politicize an issue
is the real slogan for democrats black
lives matter
only when we can politicize it you know
where's uh
mayor laurie lightweight this happens
every weekend
where's the accountability for these far
left failures
new york city this weekend a 13 year old
19 year old
they were killed seven others injured in
six shootings over 14 hours across the
city of new york
unfortunately rather than bluntly
acknowledge the role that democrats
anti-police defunding policies
are are causing in the fueling this
crime surge
democratic nominee for mayor well his
name is eric adams the democrat
praising biden's commitment to quote
redefine the ecosystem of public safety
whatever that means
now thankfully there's an independent
and a republican named curtis sliwa
who's running on
refund the police and bring back the
policies that worked under rudy giuliani
but take a look at the democrat we can't
continue to respond to
symptoms it's time to respond to the
underlying
causes of violence in our city this
president is making it clear
he's going to redefine the ecosystem of
public safety
and that includes identifying the role
of police
schools families
resources employment this is where we
need to go as
a country well first let's be honest
this president makes
nothing clear one activist in the bronx
in new york says these communities need
help
and need to reduce the tension between
officers in the community
she's pushing back against the defund
agenda here to explain more
is community activist melody jimenez is
with us along with leo 2.0 terrell
mr jimenez thank you so much for being
with us i was glad you said what you
said
uh they cut a billion dollars from the
new york police department
we now are shattering last year's record
in terms of violence and murders
injuries to cops and and deaths etc uh
defund dismantle reimagine i don't know
why don't we go back to what brought the
murder rate from nearly 3 000 down to
300 and that's stop and frisk and
funding the police what do you think
i can definitely say i agree with what
you just stated i think it's important
that we keep public safety
number one priority in new york city the
crime rate has spiked
and i think it's time for a mayor that
is willing to ensure that
nypd is funded the correct way where
they're comfortable to come out and do
their jobs because their jobs are
difficult they come out every day and
risk their lives
and i think it's something that people
need to pay attention to
let me speak on nypd are you under fire
for
the statements that you're making
because you want to save lives and you
want
strong policing
at this moment sean i'm not under fire i
have a great connection with the
community
i work with mothers i lose their kids
that are affected by gun gang and street
violence
so as of this moment i have support of
the mothers and local
members of the community i'll take the
support of moms they
you know what we all love our children
don't we we want them to be
we want law and order and safety and
security so every
child in america can actually pursue
happiness without it you can't
leo 2.0 terrell by the way big news
tonight
uh larry elder 1.0 apparently has
announced he's running for governor
you're going to be supporting our friend
hey uh i will be providing as much
support as i can
i'll i'll be providing as much support
as i can uh
all right with my uh current duties
okay i think you could speak out on this
show leo there's no rules here okay you
can say what's on your mind
yes um let's talk about this another
weekend
more violence and this is all noise to
me this reimagining stuff
because joe biden said he would
reallocate funds from
away from the police uh we know that he
didn't mention it all last summer when
the riots were going on we know that
kamala harris
you know promoted a bail fund so rioters
can get back out on the street and
and back to the activities of throwing
ricks and
and rocks and bottles etc uh and
starting fires and everything else we
saw
let me be as clear as i can that meeting
in washington dc at the white house that
was a dog and pony show
nothing was done there talking about gun
control gun rights
no it is crime allowed by democrats and
democratic cities
and i'm sad news for for new yorkers
eric adams
he went to washington dc to kiss the
ring of joe bite
i mean until he criticized aoc until he
criticized
the defunding police until he
articulated his position
separate from the progressive left he's
just like de blasio so he's not going to
change anything
he got excited going to the white house
and kissing joe biden's ring
the problem is this the issue about
crime is going to be
an issue for 2022 and the democrats have
lost that issue
and i i really feel sorry for miss him
in this because
honestly she's not getting any support
from the lawmakers in new york city
all right we're going to keep our eye on
this i'm optimistic and i'm okay with
that because sometimes you have to fight
for change
and at this moment the local politicians
are very aware of how i feel
and they seem to scatter when i give
statements but they're understanding the
importance of
because i definitely go to different yes
i i hope
i hope you stay active and i hope your
voice is loud
because lives need to be saved this is
our national treasure these are our kids
this is our american family lives are
lost every weekend
you can predict every weekend how many
sad it's pathetic and it's preventable
leo melody thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else